what's going on there citizens the reject
Nation we are going to do an epic two-parter
reaction here because on the streaming service
we're watching on it they've combined part
one and part two here for season four I'm
assuming it's episode 11 and 12 combined because
sometimes with the streaming services you
just don't know it could just be one long
episode or they've just combined both of them
but anyway it's called The Fugitive or just
fugitive of Brooklyn Nine-Nine John how are
you I am excited I like the Harrison Ford
movie so I hope this draws heavily from that
how are you hilarious ladies and gentlemen
leave a like they'd be very much appreciated
as always full length Reaction watch along
as we sync it with your own copy for benign
are available over at our patreon page for
super sexy rejects cover a whole bunch of
stuff exclusively over there as well alrighty
ladies and Gentlemen let's see what this epicness
is all about
[Music]
[Music] I haven't heard this song in a while
[Music] we have an opening there's a full
on action scene [Music] and I forgot my Pico
oh that dude's hilarious we just haven't decided
whose apartment we're going to live in I think
Jake should move in definitely Amy's prison
van overturned on Nevin Street it was carrying
nine convicts who are now at large this is
a Manhunt damn residence Warehouse Farmhouse
hen house outhouse and dog house in the area
your fugitive's name is Dr Richard Kim yes
yes none of them are named Kimball I didn't
kill my wife you're supposed to go I don't
care I don't care Let The Manhunt begin whoever
catches the most fugitives gets to keep their
apartment loser moves in with the winner all
right I'm in oh wow if you like sleeping in
a bed with a thousand and pillows well I hope
you like sharing my one great towel didn't
buy it it was in the apartment when I moved
in Gross I am completely on board you need
your own space I had a painting studio in
my apartment was this in the 90s did you wear
overalls and no shirt every chance I got yeah
yeah and then the kids came along you don't
have to paint now
[Music] Terry loves acrylics Jake moving in
with you is my dream come true your apartment
is two blocks away from mine Jake will be
able to pop by anytime imagine it he's had
a tough day he's fighting with Amy you know
how he let things escalate there are only
two witnesses who are close enough to the
crash to see something one's on his way here
already his name is Marshawn Lynch Marshawn
Lynch Marshawn Lynch the football player I
don't know his Hobbies he's a funny football
player how come they never make quesadillas
with sausage you throw some tomato sauce in
there and call it a pizza dealer what you
think what is going
Escape convict number one you can put your
bourbon holding with the other three convicts
wait other three yeah Santiago and Boyle brought
them in that's right it's three to one oh
[__] needing this anymore since you'll
be moving in with me a towel yeah your towel
oh because it never fully dries
thermal imaging baby thermal imaging baby
I got this flow check performance polo with
moisture wicking technology take a look at
this map of the world you just keep one of
those on you of course in case I ever need
to prove my point in an argument fine [Laughter]
really I'm gonna do that where did you grow
up where were you born what do you mind in
there sir a child tying his tie
oh man come on where did you guys even come
from your nightmares hey Amy allow me to introduce
you to Big Bertha security we went to Homeland
Security yeah this beauty comes fully equipped
with thermal imaging a satellite link up this
is ridiculous and she's also got a holding
cell which is big enough for three perks Jake
counting this guy how many perps have been
caught in place in the three purp set well
Sarge we placed three perps in the three perp
cell so the three purp sales full of three
purposes
oh drone a little help oh my God
I had a friend of work for that drone company
when they started out draw better we have
no idea what this is I think it's a cookie
it's not pizza it's a cookie pizza another
case another case salt it's like Google translator
this is good we're gonna crack this diazia
nope she just need to take a dump yo you know
it was a dump we can use Big Bertha to tap
into the security cameras oh
wow that is cool Homeland Security I'm going
up on my own yes sentience it's Westworld
oh wait a minute search I don't have eyes
on that room hang on I'll find it no God is
so fast what do you want you let me walk out
of this building and get into a car if anyone
tries to stop the score is tied left whoever
finds him wins yeah I guess you could say
he's the golden snitch wait was that a Harry
Potter reference God damn it really was I
started reading them because you love them
so much remember when I called in sick the
other day I was at home reading order of the
Phoenix crazy oh I'm gonna catch this last
fugitive win the bet and then we're going
to live together for the rest of our relationship
just you and me and towel makes three cool
cool cool cool cool cool just so you know
at the end of the six books oh no don't dude
you dare that was almost a real spoiler when
the choir shouts the loudest the most powerful
one is silent that doesn't even make any sense
well I might have paraphrased it incorrectly
Rob do you want to share your experience with
the group gladly okay so you know how there's
a Subterranean race of lizard people living
beneath the city who control our minds with
their pheromones yes yes of course escaped
murderer where would I hide Pizza Hut where
oh I have no idea I just thought if I gasped
I could force an epiphany and I did now that
didn't work either or did it still no unless
stop it
I just told him I saw one of them slip back
into his lizard home under the streets that's
where they make their soup oh my God he's
onto something Captain don't try to be nice
by giving it crazy it's a manhole cover he
said that the lizard people live under the
streets he means the sewers he saw someone
go from the van into the sewers look it's
a manhole cover
go down into a manhole and Escape into the
sewer near The Crab side copy that we're on
it yeah we're also on it Jeselnik this friendly
competition thing is really making them yeah
top of their game right now back [Applause]
forward back forward use that Universal back
line forward and we're gonna go yes foreign
[Laughter]
shut up I hear something please don't shoot
each other NYPD free to keep your hand so
we can see them [Music] you have the right
to an attorney if you cannot afford an attorney
what will be appointed for you why did you
stop I'm done you win what I love you I want
to move into your apartment oh I love you
too oh my God what a beautiful moment and
you guys Amy's ovulating as we speak wow
oh that's sweet when we were back there racing
through the Miranda Rights I just looked over
at you and thought you're awesome and you're
good at doing things I mean sure I'll miss
towel but your happiness is worth way more
than winning some stupid bat oh you deserve
the towel your apartment is better than mine
in every way imaginable you want to know my
first thought was when we dropped into the
sewer smells like home no he's lying Ninja
Turtles come on Terry we were in a sewer he's
guns to think about the turtles yeah I'm gunsta
Terry quit being such a Malfoy yeah Terry
he's a gunster he's your van drive he had
pictures of my family he said he'd kill him
if I didn't help so I crashed the van and
jeselnick took my clothes but then where's
the guy we thought was the van driver he vanished
whoa I was killed at least five people he's
been in the system since he was 11. that's
when he sold four thousand dollars from his
foster family and burned their house down
this is the Foster family yeah why did you
see who the brother is come on man I need
your help to take down your brother
[Laughter] hey babe nice legs why are you
boxes so you would know I'm not wearing a
wire your buddy Scott said I had to ah that
makes sense Scott's a perv you watch it from
go home hahaha
George is a murderer now and he just escaped
from prison we think he might be trying to
flee the country you want me to help you catch
him like when X-Men teamed up with Magneto
to stop apocalypse yeah right we need a theme
song the Pontiac Bandit and Jay got cops oh
taking down Crooks in the streets where they
live flooding with girls who will hop for
the bass there's a talking police dog that
helps them solve crime bring them in you told
me to cut a deal I thought you'd maybe drop
charges on one or two felonies but do you
know how many crimes we're forgiving six that's
not so bad hundred if Judy doesn't lead us
to his brother he doesn't get immunity look
cap I want to see George behind bars as much
as you do I hate my brother you can relate
to that right sir remember how Furious you
got that time your sister ended an email with
THX the game is on game is a foot like this
never mind it's not possible sure
damn Rosa how did you do that I have a dark
pass
now you know my deepest shame cool
yep [Laughter] a text change and I'm not on
any of them there's a Hitchcock Terry Amy
Rosen chain there's even a Hitchcock Gina
Scully chain wow Charles poyle it's off the
chain that is sad damn excluded you because
you're kind of an over texter over texture
so you don't remember the time you sent 97
unanswered texts in a five minute span my
phone vibrated itself off the desk I think
it was committing suicide [Laughter] well
the only thing we have to go on is the word
of one of your criminal friends criminals
that's how you see us is it a crime to steal
bread to feed your family or to sell some
weed so you can buy video games or steal video
games because you smoked all that weed
we'll go do something with the hell out of
it
he's not a cop he can't be wearing any of
this it's just a windbreaker it's not like
I gave him a badge and a gun he has both of
those things it's not loaded I just want a
[__] and say a cool cop catchphrase New
York's finest just got a whole lot finer
treat her gently you know that's not a nice
car right say that again that's what I thought
I'll be the vineyard I actually felt pretty
dramatic I was like this wasn't funny you
all want me to join your stupid text chains
I am 100 in these last 24 hours have just
been hell oh it's just my former lover hello
sister [Laughter] you're on the office exchange
are you serious this is amazing yeah well
I was totally against it but Amy felt bad
because you seemed so pathetic it worked does
he have a scar on her left cheek maybe what's
the shape of the scar just a general slashing
I'll head towards her you go around back in
case she makes a break for it [Music] this
is a root Scarface friend is a ruse he wanted
us out of there so he could help his brother
steal the egg shot glasses of soup oh you're
wondering how I got the whole tray Charming
right out of her hey foreign because you can't
parkour up a wall it's everything I don't
like how baggy basketball shorts are I even
shook my business some skateboarders the other
day and that's something worse [Music] oh
no Sherry needs for eating glasses it's not
that bad sorry yes it is I used to be Batman
oh no I'm his dad his dumb wheat getting shot
at the operator
I mean I'll watch that origin story
somebody knocked out the ballet stole all
the cars every single one so George was here
looks like Doug Judy was right after all huh
captain why aren't you say anything it's because
you're so embarrassed for being wrong
oh no gerdy shut up
oh no how do we even know George did it I
mean nobody saw him but there was a prolific
car thief at the scene of the crime you talking
about me I'm a cop now no you're not if I
don't have a badge and a gun The Thin Blue
Line just got thick as hell
yes I'd rather get hit by a bus then get one
more from you Charles fine I've been kicked
out of things before at Camp I found a slam
book that the Lunch Ladies had written about
me oh I need to be included so badly I'll
do whatever you say I literally have zero
pride and that's what I like to hear Charles
I'll make the introductions wait we can't
just be Europeans what country are we from
what languages do you speak French Spanish
some Portuguese obviously Greek enough Flemish
to get by what about you brought um I can
do a pretty good Italian accent you think
you could milk me
terrible dinero I don't know
I'm just making America okay
nice cars and I might have a buyer this is
Maxine Dubois International millionaire goes
you he doesn't speak any English this is his
lawyer Carl mangerson hey I'm a lawyer cobra
I mostly deal with scrap and crap you know
oh what'd you eating there Serge Cream of
Wheat it's easy to chew and it keeps you regular
it's a favorite dish of the elderly why don't
I get your wheelchair and a box of diapers
that's how he escaped he dressed up like an
old lady
[Music] oh George is here he's out back let's
go right now NYPD don't move that crap he's
getting away oh no oh all right we can run
right through it these suits are fire resistant
these suits are not fire resistant they're
not why are they so expensive
you had to have known better we're gonna show
you a text and then two potential responses
you need to tell us which is more appropriate
Amy writes leaving the Virgin Festival Gina
[Laughter] 597 596. smiley face smiley face
cat smiley face thumbs up or okay it's a trick
question the text requires no response dang
looking for us put your guns down turn around
slowly what the hell Judy ah Judy so bro you
friends with this cop nah it's thirsty ass
[__] just desperate for attention first
yes [__] okay captain now I know you're
gonna step in and defend me well you were
begging me to compliment earlier oh my gosh
if you're not friends you won't mind if I
waste them right of course he Minds I mean
sure we're enemies but in like a playful way
like Tom and Jerry oh my God was Tom trying
to eat cherry life is alive no no those can't
be my last words hi karamba the hell oh nice
we got to put bullets in his brother's gun
I knew you didn't betray me I said that accusatorly
but I'm very happy
it's on you they was always friends now imma
get my immunity the ghost of the talking dog
haunts the priest
and that was a bummer note to end on
hahaha
[Laughter] I underestimated your honesty and
Peralta I underestimated your instincts yeah
I'm gonna need a lot more from you than that
fine you're a good cop even if you are a thirsty
ass [__] solve a pretty intense murder
there's crap all over me hey Captain got you
a little something something dirty nope but
she is the exact same make model and color
oh my God you stole this I can't be driving
a stolen relax man I bought it at a used car
lot for like 600 this is not a nice vehicle
hello sexarella sexarella would you mind taking
a look before he hit send Charles you've trained
for this moment okay we trust you just send
it come here good job oh boy I'm gonna do
it
oh no she's gonna hit what
oh whoa
I don't think there's gonna be a bus yeah
and and so forcefully God she just did
damn oh wow Gina's dead and I think Doug Judy's
brother was from a Saw movie I mean I heard
that she dozens or stay on the show I think
they'd kill her off no I just I wouldn't think
so either I don't know I mean I see something
like this and I'm like expecting like a full
body cast plot line rather than her actually
dying and being off the show but at the same
time uh I mean it would certainly be an interesting
Rabbit Hole to follow the characters now imagine
what it will do to boil is this when they
take like their four month break oh maybe
oh maybe they did have like a long break right
yeah between December and April or whatever
that was yeah yeah I guess so um Dizzle yeah
that was uh it's a lasting impression why
are we well if that was for last episode she
held Boyle learn to text and that is the lasting
impact every time Boyle uses a phone in the
show we'll think of Gina um yeah I hope it's
like a tragic story for her where she's like
you know like in a casket and it's suffering
neurological brain damage and then when she's
in the hospital like at the end of the season
she's like you know Pearl to kill me pull
the kill my now and then he ends up having
to pull the plug on her walks away and commit
euthanasia I think that I think I think after
four seasons you gotta start having just a
little more drama infused it's a really spice
it up and oh [__] you know just keep those
emotional beats heavy a little harder than
the comedy will be that much fun you can still
have the con like after he pulls the plug
you know you can do a gag where like the electronic
bed like does crazy thing with her corpse
you know it's funny because she's dead so
you're just flopping around and all that stuff
but you know what good woman before that was
yeah was a really touching emotional yeah
always killing a woman's funny yeah it's funny
this is the funniest death that's why I didn't
really laugh during Dahmer uh you know it's
unfortunate there was a lot of Comedy potential
humor is just not laughing I don't get why
people think this is so funny this is not
a funny joke but what is funny is when you
trust yourself that's funny oh this was this
was epic this was great I don't know how most
of you guys experience this part one Parts
you imagine if it was cut up it was you know
week to week uh but I I think watching in
one go is actually a really strong choice
I I loved it like the first half is is funny
it's like a good funny episode um but but
the second half is hilarious like the second
half is true but once they team up um Doug
Judy and Andy Samberg like I I think Craig
Robinson is a wonderful talent and I I think
this is my favorite role that he does sure
uh there's there's because normally like Craig
Robinson is is more uh he's just a little
more deadpan more dried and I think he brings
that subtle delivery that he does a real like
natural a humorous delivery that he has but
there's a little more Charisma in life and
a little a little a little more goofball nature
to his character that is more childlike you
want to hang out with or he's also less of
a roaster like Doug Judy does roast but I
feel like other Craig Robinson rolls roast
harder yeah yeah no this guy has a lot more
fun and he seems to be more endearing and
be more bemused by people too and so I I do
I do like his character a lot and so it's
my personal favorite role of Craig Robinson
but no that that was like a the last half
was was so funny it was hilarious and it's
actually a brilliant two-parter to set it
up where it's a it's a fun Manhunt episode
for you gotta capture all these criminals
and then you got the one remaining person
left where you make it a little bit more uh
personal and focused so you get this wrap
around or you get this two part where one
ends on they're gonna move in together Jake
and Amy that's was really touching note and
then to get the second half uh who was I don't
know I don't think we've seen it where it's
like Peralta Holt and uh Doug Judy yeah there's
a great Trio who's who's so funny and they're
the reoccurring bits too you of the theme
song and and it does have you questioning
like oh it's gonna have a is he a Trader is
he a Trader and then you can only figure out
like moments before it happens like what the
next turn is going to be but I like that the
ends on a turn of he actually was on their
side uh for for this for this particular situation
he was actually helping them out so and it's
perfectly comedic that yeah it's like you're
immune all of your past transgressions are
wiped or have been expunged and he's just
gonna go right back to Pizza yeah like it
manages to have that it has its cake and eats
it too by being this epic Doug Judy you know
each season has one so yeah this is like the
most epic one yet and then you're like but
damn if he turns over a leaf and they're just
friends like what is this gonna do for the
show and then of course he's just gonna be
like no I'm just gonna go back to doing and
it's perfect because then yeah you know it'll
show up again later and it'll be you know
a treat as it always is but yeah having the
three of them together and having that tension
I think it was really lovely you know it was
a this two-parter had the right amount you
said it during the scene where uh Holt tells
off Judy about Gertie out front of the the
venue and like I think the previous part with
Jake and Amy did a really nice job of having
those moments just be sweet and endearing
and and not worrying it's like effortless
it's like it's not even concerned with the
comedy so much as it's just like it slides
you into this character moment and here I
thought they did nicely to do that too or
yeah with Holt at his car at least you have
these couple of moments that are just genuine
and do kind of catch you and and I think it's
nice the first episode yeah you have this
you know Manhunt you have this bet but you
also have something loving and endearing and
here it's more something serious more something
that stops you in your tracks in a different
way in an opposite way yeah and uh and yeah
it's like as a yin and a Yang I thought this
did nicely to exemplify what some of the best
Brooklyn 99 episodes do which is hilarious
comedy all obviously and all the character
stuff but knowing wisely where to place an
office authentic moment well yeah I think
the the moment where he is yelling about the
car is supposed to be funny for some reason
it just read his like about insulting the
name of the car yeah but when it's when it
happened I was like this is actually like
a dramatic seem to be like laughing about
that at all oh well yeah it's like it's it's
it it's funny to me because it would have
been made the later bits so much funnier yeah
it's like I got the sense that I wasn't necessarily
supposed to be laughing at that but at the
same time it is inherently funny what is happening
there yeah because they to treat that moment
so serious even even Doug Judy's reaction
to him was like damn man like calm down like
like he like he was about to get like he it
was probably like a dramatic scene where you're
like geez it didn't mean anything by it you
know like sorry dude it's okay yeah but so
then so then when it does get taken and all
the Jabs about the car actually being like
cheap and not really anything like that it
made it that much funnier yeah because we
knew how serious Holt took this car uh well
and it was the right amount it was it was
close enough to the ground like it wasn't
so absurd that it's like I feel like we have
all had a moment like that where you're ribbing
something or you're riffing on somebody and
and then you realize that you've hit a nerve
and they are actually serious about something
you didn't think was that serious and so like
that moment rang true to that you know whereas
a lot of the humor on on the show is absurd
once a month though a subscriber or a patron
who does not take kindly to something I say
um sorry I get that but the other B story
lines too in the uh in the second half are
also funny like the story about boiled texting
is that I think that would be a it's a relate
I've never particularly been in that situation
where like why don't I I generally don't I'm
in a couple group chats and I oh the test
I'm the least interactive not the biggest
participant of group chats uh but I I don't
so I don't I don't itch to be a part of a
group chat but I I I I it did a great job
of setting it up that even if if I was in
that situation I would feel like extremely
left out yes you know surely I'd be like I
just want to be in it not that I want to be
like an active participant all the time but
that would be hurtful if they like kept it
from me yes you know yeah and I think they
that's what made it really sing and but it's
also really relatable we're like God you know
whenever this person texts they just blow
up my phone and it's it's stopped it's insistent
yeah I hate it so it's like they crashed or
like bring two relatable things out of that
have nothing to do with police work um but
but it is funny it's a it's a it's a funny
relatable thing I think a lot of us deal with
with group text situations or dexters um and
the it was a throw one a Rosa Rosa territory
yeah that was like the least funny one but
there were still some hilarious jokes yeah
like that I think the writing and the editing
was solid and yeah it was really really really
funny um and I like the pair of Rosa and Terry
when they do put them together yeah and I
like the understanding of Terry always being
all that hard that's always what made Terry
uh such a sweetheart is the fact that he has
always been like an older person at heart
like he's got this it's an old look and appearance
of of this like they're super physically fit
Action Hero yeah and he can play action heroes
one of The Expendables
he is that guy but you know he's such a softy
a teddy bear on the inside he's old soul at
heart so I think fleshing that out yeah there's
just some really fun that joke about Batman's
dad oh my god oh oh what was the line even
the guided an opera or something yeah what
was the build up of like talking about him
like pretty much just being a loser then ending
it's just dying at the office yeah it was
perfect it was a perfect line yeah does any
of you don't really know that Batman backstory
whichever you know where it's going yeah it's
just like insulting like dumbass dad's losers
average guy and also he died yeah I thought
this was uh brilliantly done and uh like a
pretty good production value for this I'm
like they threw down yeah like they needed
this one to be special and then with a cliffhanger
like that yeah one I mean I guess if they
were gonna take a long break I guess that's
what you do you're like oh damn and on an
event two-parter even though this aired in
two parts you know and then and on a big cliffhanger
love how bus hits are are the most easy to
generally the most easy to see come well I
didn't see a bus hit coming it was like really
obvious it was about to get hit by a car but
I didn't see a bus hitting her yeah and 99
of the time I could see a bus hit coming but
I guess a bus hit has bigger implications
so I didn't see a busted coming in this I
thought she was gonna get like hit by a car
and it was gonna be like you know falls on
top of it or just flies over and like and
it should be injured but a bus hit with especially
the way that played was like ooh that's serious
um well yeah yeah I mean you're like she's
either got to be broken every bone in her
body or is being dragged underneath right
now because there was not much low clearance
I would love if the next episode is she's
just uh working she's just bad it's barely
barely in barely an injury yeah like you look
at it up and about since recovering from the
hospital yeah yeah you know I could survive
anything I'm Gina linetti ah yeah this was
a this was a very big Delight Afternoon Delight
sky rockets everything excelled ladies and
gentlemen what did you think about this uh
two-parter leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe hi hey this one is the
most active one of them all the fastest one
the one is always awake and wanting to play
constantly he just wants to run around attention
and he's always h-u-n-g-r-y he knows what
that word is so I can't say it out loud and
he doesn't know what it spouts he doesn't
know what that spouse what what Harry Potter's
character oh what a spouse he doesn't know
it he'll learn guitar
ten minutes of cat love run away run away
and go get into something that you can eat
all right guys well um Merry Christmas and
let's send this for the patreon
Maria Hammond I wanted to shout you out because
you have gifted Olivia and I with some truly
spectacular gifts um because we are to be
wet very very soon it is true and uh the it's
just like you've been uh obnoxiously generous
like you've not just made it a more exciting
time to get married but also uh a better Christmas
overall and a great way to start the new year
so thank you for always sharing your your
soul being vulnerable with me but uh and then
gifting us but you can literally stop I want
you to do it enough you can stop your love
is received I I I love the hell out of you
but you've gone like what above and beyond
this is so many ways that I almost don't I
mean like I've shown you photos where some
of the stuff is uh in our home but yeah this
is you know if you want to keep going you
can but yeah you can literally stop right
now and you're covered for like at least a
year you know yeah maybe until we start to
be like hey Maria so I feel a little neglected
over here so thank you my dear for uh being
amazing I hope you're able to have a great
Christmas with your family and I I also hope
that that 2023 ends up being a sharper year
for you than 2022 was I really do love you
thank you [Music]